Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Sag mal, kannst du mir mal einen Kaffee machen, bitte?
Das tut mir leid Tim, aber das geht nicht. Ich bin ein Teekessel.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer vierhundertundachtzehn vom siebzehnten Januar zwanzigzweiundzwanzig. Wir begrüßen euch alle.
Und ihr wisst ja, bald, ne, die goldenen Zwanziger, man sieht sie schon, ich habe nochmal nachgeschaut. Also wenn man ganz genau hinschaut,
am Horizont ist ein leichtes Glühen. Es ist eine ganz dünne Linie so, aber sie hat äh einen äh einen schönen Schein.
Und ähm dem Drosten und dem hast du's jetzt auch schon erklärt, ne?
Die in die die ja die schwenken langsam auf meine Linie ein. Können natürlich jetzt noch nicht so raus damit ne. Sonst sind ja auch alle so ein bisschen geschockt. Stell dir mal vor morgen wäre die Pandemie einfach so zu Ende.
Wenn die Leute doch überhaupt gar nicht darauf gar nicht klar kommen.
Mit der Pandemie kommen sie auch nicht klar, aber äh man muss das jetzt langsam aus, wie wie nennt man das aus Phasen, ne?
Aus Fäden, genau.
Entwöhnen. Wir müssen das jetzt entwöhnen.
Genau und da und da aber da trage ich gerne zu bei und es ist halt auch so ein bisschen wie mit Reiseplanung,
Also eine Reise ist halt einfach dann schon geiler, wenn man sich drauf freuen kann.
Immer früh buchen und dann dann dann weiß man, das wird dann äh stattfinden und dann freut man sich auch mehr drüber. Hat man auch mehr davon. Also wenn man sich jetzt schon auf das Pandemie-Ende auch freut, dann ist das auch noch geiler als sonst schon.
Ja und das ist also man hat ja auch jetzt schon was davon. Man ist ja jetzt auch nicht so als müsste man den Leuten jetzt die Leute daran erinnern so ey vergesst nicht, euch auf das Ende der Pandemie zu freuen.
Da bin ich mir bei manchen Leuten nicht so sicher.
Stimmt.
Kommt alles.
Aber erst mal äh kommt was anderes, nämlich noch mal ein Blick in die Vergangenheit. Nämlich in die Vergangenheit des Internets,
Ich habe auch äh äh habe heute übrigens, äh weiß nicht, hast du den Tweet gesehen? Ich habe mal meinen meinen ältesten Post, der noch im Netz zu finden ist, äh rausgesucht.
Nee, habe ich nicht. Was ist das?
Das ist eine Usnet-Message, die ich geschrieben habe, news Punkt Config. So.
Hat wahrscheinlich irgendwas mit den goldenen 20ern zu tun, oder.
Da habe ich mir schon das erste Mal Gedanken darüber gemacht.
Nee, da war einer aus so einem Alter, wo so das Jahr 2tausend echt weit weg war.
Zwar ist es 33 Jahre her tatsächlich äh Dezember, ich glaube 12. Dezember achtundachtzig,
nämlich mal in so einem Usnet-Archiv geschaut, also für äh die Leute, die nicht wissen, was das ist. Das Use Net ist so ein.
Vorläufer des ähm.
Also es ich will nicht sagen Vorläufer des Internet. Das Internet gab's ja in dem Sinne schon technisch so, ne. Bloß da wohl halt so Dateien kopiert et cetera und das war so ein Separat und,
Parallel dazu gab's halt diese ganzen Mailboxwelten und dann gab's halt auch noch dieses Usit. Konnte man halt im Prinzip zwei
Dinge miteinander austauschen, nämlich,
Mail und News und News war quasi so wie Foren. Ne, es gibt also News Groups,
hierarchisches Namensschema im Titel äh hatten,
Beispiel gab's DE Punkt ORG Punkt CC oder das ganze CCC Gewusel schon damals äh sich äh,
abgetreten hat sozusagen ähm so also deutsche Gruppen und dann der ganze Technikkram und dann halt auch noch so ein paar Meter äh Gruppen, wo es dann sozusagen um die um das Netzwerk selber ging.
Einem von denen habe ich irgendwie gepostet, weil mein Rechnername, den ich mir gewählt hatte, Impuls hieß äh meine Maschine damals.
Da gab's noch eine im im Netz. Die hatte den gleichen Namen. Irgendwo in,
und das führte dann zu äh Konflikten, weil's halt damals diese ganzen hierarchischen Domains noch überhaupt nicht gab. Auch nicht für für E-Mail. Na ja und dann habe ich da halt irgendwie was zu äh geschrieben und das war,
Vor 33 Jahren so. Da habe ich so das erste Mal meinen Finger in diese Suppe reingehalten und damals waren irgendwie alle noch lieb zueinander weitgehend. Das hat sich dann schnell geändert.
Für den geklärt.
Mit dem also ich meine offensichtlich hast du ja dem Medium nicht vertraut, weil du hast deine Adresse nochmal drunter geschrieben.
Damals war das so, da hat man verstehst du? Also man kann sich ja nicht vorstellen, wie klein das war damals. Das war verstehst du? Jenseits jeglicher Öffentlichkeit.
Und und du hieß und du hieß auch nicht Tim Britlov sondern Gin Tonic.
Ja, das war so ein Spitzname, der äh nicht lange gehalten hat, weil er's als Leute angefangen haben mich wirklich so zu nennen, dachte ich mir so, nee, ist eigentlich nichts für mich.
Ist auch schwierig in der Kneipe, wenn du irgendwie immer die Frage nach Gin Tonic gerufen wird und ähm ja.
Äh bei mir haben Nick Names noch nie so richtig verfangen. Na ja, aber schön ist halt so dieses äh siehst du ja dann auch in diesem Post dieses ähm,
Der sogenannte Bangpass, ja, also wenn man mir quasi eine Mail schreiben wollte, dann musste man den kompletten Pfad angeben, wo die Mail denn dann letztlich lang soll, damit sie auf meinem Computer landet, weil's diese Ecknotation einfach noch nicht gab.
Ja, das heißt, du musst es halt irgendwie wissen
Wie kommst du von deinem Rechner zu einem Rechner, der heißt Ujo Net, was so ein zentraler Knoten in diesem Usnit war und dann muss es das
dann Ausrufezeichen Unido, das ist die Universität Dortmund, das war quasi das Einfallstor für Deutschland.
Dann Bang Focus, das war so eine so eine Firma in äh Hannover, wo ich damals war, wo.
Leute, die was von Computern und Netz verstanden, arbeiteten und dann gab's da einen Computer, der hieß Focus 63 und da war ich der User Gin Tonic und wenn man mir halt eine Mail schreiben wollte, dann musste man dieses ganze Konvolut angeben.
Waren noch Zeiten. Ich sage dir, die Leute wissen ja gar nicht, wie gut sie's heutzutage haben.
Wie gut's ihnen geht mit ihren E-Mails.
So sieht's aus.
Auf jeden Fall hatte ich damals viele Probleme irgendwie Bouncende Nachrichten, die irgendwie die ganze Zeit übern Teich gingen und viel Kosten erzeugten. Bei den Leuten, die hin und her schickt wie in Griff zu kriegen. Das war schon alles ein bisschen wild. Na ja gut, auf jeden Fall,
habe ich so gemacht und ähm warum erwähne ich das? Weil einfach es immer wieder schön ist, mal so ein bisschen in dieser Internethistorie zu blättern, wie anders die Dinge da waren und,
Jetzt müssen wir natürlich auf die vierhundertachtzehn.
Anders meinst du, dass sich dass sich jetzt gar keiner geflammt hat danach oder oder was meinst du, ist jetzt anders.
Nee. Heutzutage.
Mit der Flämerei, das ging dann auch bald los. Also so in den.
Neunziger war das dann schon drin. Aber ich würde sagen so in den in den äh Ende der achtziger Jahre war das alles noch äh war das alles noch ganz anständig. Da wollten sich alle noch gegenseitig helfen.
Äh so in den 90ern ging das dann so langsam,
das dann so langsam kaputt und man schrie sich an und alle wollten Recht behalten und waren äh unflätig und dann kam halt so was wie die Netikette auf, so nach dem Motto hm wir könnten doch mal probieren als wir alle alle lieb zueinander sind, was haltet ihr denn da,
und und alle so, ja nee. Komm mir nicht so.
121288er vorm Mauerfall.
Ja. Genau. Also irgendwie, ich glaube.
Ey stimmt, du hast ja sogar die Adresse noch mit West Germany angegeben, klar. Natürlich muss er.
Genau mit vierstelliger Postleitzahl, alles. Total.
Authentisch so, ne.
Tim ey.
Aber ich war ich war dabei.
Keine große Leistung, aber es war auf jeden Fall schön, dieses ganze Netz langsam so äh wachsen zu sehen. Na ja,
wollte ich jetzt eigentlich zu sprechen kommen auf unseren Statuscode. Vierhundertachtzehn,
Es ist ja, äh wir haben das hier schon mehrfach äh glaube ich erwähnt, so das ganze Netz hat sich ja in den Anfangstagen und im Prinzip auch heute noch über so offene Standards definiert. Die
die man in den sogenannten RFC-Dokumenten zusammenschreibt. Das heißt request forcument und das ist im Prinzip man veröffentlichen so ein so ein mehrseitiges,
was so eine einheitliche Formatierung zu haben hat und dann äh veröffentlicht man damit.
Quasi so ein Protokoll entworfen. Tatsächlich sind die dann eigentlich auch damit schon mehr oder weniger fertig. Äh wenn man das dann später mal überarbeitet, dann gibt's dann ein neues RFC. Die kriegen dann so Nummerierungen.
Hat sich dann relativ bald auch so ein bisschen der Spaß eingestellt, dass man so am 1. April eines Jahres immer so einen RFC raushaut, was irgendwie nicht ganz so ernst gemeint ist.
Und so war es dann halt auch äh,
zehn Jahre nach meinem Post am 1. April 1998 wurde das RFC 2324 veröffentlicht mit dem Titel Hyper Text Coffee Pott Kontrollprotokoll
HTCPCP eins Punkt null und das war in gewisser Hinsicht sehr ähm visionär
Weil es eigentlich schon in seiner Beschreibung äh so ein bisschen dieses diese Vision des Internet of Things vorweggenommen hat. Etwas woran damals überhaupt auch nicht nur im Ansatz zu denken war.
Also also allein schon der Gedanke, dass jede Kaffeemaschine irgendwie ihre eigene IP-Adresse hat, das das,
Das hat schon irgendwie äh für Erheiterung gesorgt. Aber.
Sollte man das tun.
Ja, aber tatsächlich steht dann hier in dieser Beschreibung auch drin irgendwie wie die
that is corsing the consumtion of the IP for a dress base. Ja also das da,
vorhergesehen, dass das sozusagen die kompletten Adressen des äh damaligen IPV4 Protokolls, also ist ja auch eigentlich auch das heutige so, aber jetzt haben wir ja V sechs aus diesen Gründen, dass das halt irgendwie nicht ausreichen würde, ne. Aber Leute,
und äh Remote Control auf die Vices such as coffee Pods so that they may wake up to Freshly Brut Coffee.
Also diese ganze Vision, die wir jetzt gerade haben mit diesem Smartphone und so, die steckt da irgendwie eigentlich äh drin,
nimmt es halt das HTP-Protokoll so ein bisschen äh auf eine Schippe und sagt, ja wir bauen da jetzt einfach noch mal das äh,
Protokoll mit drauf,
haben's dann schön äh spezifiziert mit entsprechenden äh Kommandos. Da wurde also dann HTTP um so zwei Methoden ergänzt. Nämlich erstmal um die Methode Bro
du an deine Kaffeemaschine äh schickst, damit sie dann immer ordentlich äh brüht und du kannst dann in den Parametern genau sagen, was du denn gerne äh gebrüht haben möchtest, also welche Art, so Espresso et cetera.
Und dann äh sehr lustig und dann gibt's noch die Methode. Und die Wenn-Methode musst du dann schicken,
Wenn genug Milch in deinem Kaffee ist, das heißt die Maschine macht schon mal Milch rein und sagt,
Sag wenn's reicht. Und dann wendet's enough und dann sagst du,
Welden in dem Moment. Ist so lustig. Auf jeden Fall gibt's dann zwei Statuscodes und mit dem einen seid ihr ja alle schon vertraut, nämlich vier null sechs not acceptable, der ist hier definiert. Das ist, wenn irgendwie die Parameter nicht stimmen oder.
Äh wenn man ähm das dann eine spätere Ergänzung.
Ähm wenn wenn es sich dabei nicht um eine Kaffeemaschine handelt.
Sondern um einen Teekessel, der gar keinen Kaffee machen kann. Dann gibt's halt den HTTP-Federcode 418 I mit Teapot.
Ja
Das ist halt lustig. Später wurde es dann noch ergänzt mit dem RFC 7168. Der Hypertext Coffee Pott Control Protokoll da sind halt die, die dann noch
T-Extension haben und so und dann kann man halt auch damit noch Tee machen. Also so was gab's irgendwie immer. Das war dann irgendwie April zwanzig vierzehn.
Und ähm viele äh witzig gemeinte Sache haben's ja dann aber auch tatsächlich so in die Welt äh geschafft so,
Zum Beispiel gab's ja auch mal dann diese.
Also eigentlich schon ein bisschen ernst gemeinte aber dann immer so mit ein bisschen so Höhe begleiteten Standard des sogenannten Pack-DHCP, was die Verteilung von IP-Adressen über Wäscheklammern ist. Was wir tatsächlich auf dem ersten Camp auch wirklich zum Einsatz gebracht haben, ne, also weil,
Server, also so diese äh Systeme, die halt,
den Rechnern die Adressen mitteilen, die sie denn zu verwenden haben in einem Netzwerk, wenn sie sich da anmelden. Die haben halt damals noch nicht so richtig gut funktioniert und da war's einfach
definitiv besser, den Leuten so eine Wäscheklammer zu geben, eine IP-Adresse draufzuschreiben, die sie sich hinten an ihr Internetkabel ranklemmen, damit man irgendwie äh weiß, welche Adresse die zu verwenden haben. Auch zum Debugging.
Wunderbar. Na ja, das ist so der Internethumor, vielleicht könnt ihr was damit anfangen. Ich fand's auf jeden Fall lustig.
Auf jeden Fall. Es ist eine äh schön vor allem äh was da vorhergesehen wurde und,
Ich traue mich jetzt gar nicht zu fragen, aber das hatte doch bestimmt auch schon mal jemand ähm der noch inzwischen tatsächlich in eine IOT-Kaffeemaschine umgesetzt dieses Protokoll, oder?
Äh hat bestimmt irgendeiner umgesetzt, habe ich aber jetzt nicht so verfolgt.
Okay.
Damit können wir zu Feedback kommen würde ich sagen, ja, wir haben nämlich äh einen Kommentar von Oelsen.
Beschwert sich, dass wir nicht darauf hingewiesen haben, das alles ist eins aus den außer der Null jetzt als DVD erhältlich ist,
Bin ich verwundert? Haben wir das echt vergessen? Mann, ey. Gibt's doch nicht.
Covid hier. Also wir machen ähm also der Film,
Alles ist eins außer der Null und den wir ja hier mehrmals auch äh behandelt haben über dessen Premiere wir ja hier glaube ich auch äh gesprochen haben.
Der sich mit dem Gründer oder einem der Gründer, dem zentralen Gründer, wenn man so will, das Chaos-Computer-Klos auseinandersetzt mit Wau Holland. Ähm,
ist ja äh erstmal der Pandemie zum Opfer gefallen. Dann wurde er zum,
20sten Todestag von Wau Holland kam der nämlich glaube ich in die Kinos dann, ne? Und ähm.
Und jetzt sind sechs Monate um und deswegen kann man ihn jetzt auch auf,
DVD kaufen. Äh kriegt man überall, aber mein Vorschlag wäre, kauft ihn doch direkt bei dem bei uns verlinkten Verleih. Das ist für die quasi die,
die beste Option, ja? Ähm,
Und das ist der Verleih äh hat auch noch ganz hat noch andere coole Filme, zum Beispiel äh wildes Herz. Ja, dieser die Doku über,
hier Monchi, den Sänger von Feine Sahne Fischfilet, Film, den ich immer sehen wollte und noch nicht gesehen habe, ähm weil es natürlich auch als Doku äh den Film,
ein großer Erfolg, aber ne, eine Doku äh Erfolg im im Kino ist immer noch nicht besonders äh riesig, ne?
Von Charlie Hübner und genau ähm alles ist eins außer der Null, kann man dort kaufen. Wir ja alle drin vor, ne? Nee, also du kommst, kommst du so ja klar, also nicht nicht als direkter Protagonist, aber Ausschnitte von dir kommen ja vor, ne?
Genau äh in den Hauptrollen war Holland, Peter Glaser, Steffen Wernery, Andi Müller Magun,
am Ende komme ich auch noch ganz kurz drin vor. Tim kommt drin vor, ne, so ein CC viel CC Geschichte, viel aber auch nicht.
Und dann haben sich jetzt viele beschwert, dass der Film
nicht auf DVD at erhältlich wäre. Sagen wir mal so, der besteht ja größtenteils aus Archivaufnahmen und dafür ist DVD-Qualität, schon sagen wir mal, ein ein gewisses Oversimpling, würde ich sagen, ne.
Ja, also ich meine, man kann auch erwähnen, es gibt auch auf den Streaming-Plattformen den zu leiden und zu.
Auch machen, ja.
Ja, also gibt's bei Amazon-Preilen, gibt's bei äh Apple TV und wahrscheinlich noch irgendwas, was ich jetzt nicht gecheckt habe. Äh am Ende macht das alles Geld.
Die Leute haben irgendwie nicht mehr so viele DVD-Player. Das ist auch.
Der Blu-ray-Player, da kannst du das ja auch reintun. Das ist ja nicht wie ein CD-Player, wo du kein Vinyl mehr reintun kannst, Kinder.
Dori Player. Für dene die Intel SGX äh inklusiv die äh äh.
Warum beschweren die Leute sich denn, dass sie in dem also ich meine, okay, ich habe jetzt äh ja ich habe hier ein äh altes Thinkpad, da,
ist so ein optisches Laufwerk. Ich weiß nicht, ob's kleine DVD reintun kann, aber ich glaube schon und ähm,
man kauft so was ja nicht notwendigerweise, um's zu gucken,
sondern auch ums Anfassen zu können. Und das ist halt eine richtig schöne Plastikhülle mit einem,
Blatt Papier drin, äh das äh da hat man das Original.
Ja, aber genau. Also wenn, dann ist die Empfehlung, wenn man das kaufen möchte, wäre unsere Empfehlung direkt beim Verleih und ansonsten hat Tim hier Apple-Link oder sowas. Alles ist eins außer der Null. Wärmste Empfehlung.
Und bei uns ja hier mehrfach besprochen. Insofern danke Olsen, dass du aufmerksam aufgepasst hast, dass wir es nicht ähm dass wir's vergessen haben nochmal zu bewerben, ärgert mich ein bisschen.
Haben wir ja jetzt gemacht.
Jetzt gemacht.
Dann haben wir noch einen äh Kommentar zum Thema äh Impfpasskontrolle von Ralf. Lieber Linus und Tim, es fühlt sich also lieber Linus,
und Tim,
es fühlt sich seit Oktober so an, dass zunehmend die Koffercheck verwendet wird und häufig sogar mit dem Ausweis verglichen wird. Die Displays, Scroller werden weniger und ja, Ralf, die mit dem eingebauten QR-Code im Auge,
es ist etwas schade, dass die neue 2G Plus-Regel nicht unterstützt wird,
auch weil es nicht geplant ist dieses Feature in der Kopfpass-Check einzuführen, schmeißen wir gefühlt den Erfolg weg und kommen zu den Displays zurück.
Gut. Die Impfzertifikate sind eine europäische Lösung. Österreich hat auch eine Check-App Green Check. Die kann mehrere Varianten drei Gzweieinhalb G2G plus,
2G ein G Einreise 3G Einreise 2G plus Einreise-Booster Plus.
Aber merkst du das? Kein fünf G, da steckt doch ist doch was nicht in Ordnung.
5G wird in. Diese funktioniert auch super schlecht, deren zwei G Plus entspricht nicht 2G plus PCR-Test also nicht gleich. Ja.
War noch gleich der Name der Person, die das vollständig verstanden hat.
Äh ja also äh.
Ja, aber das ist in der Tat eine Unterlassung in dieser Koffpass-Check
äh App, dass halt diese ganze Anzeige nach wie vor nach einem nach einer Überprüfung nur den Namen uns Geburtsdatum rausschickt und eben noch diese klassische vollständig Geimpfprüfung macht, aber eben nicht anzeigt, dass das eine Booster-Impfung ist.
Genau und das ist ja auch leider nicht so einfach abzubilden, weil wenn du ein Jay-Jay Kunde bist,
dann ist ja quasi deine zweite Impfung mit einem Impfstoff deiner Wahl zur Aufpussterung des Johnson und Johnson. Ein Booster.
Ja theoretisch geht es dann auch, wenn du deine ganzen anderen Zertifikate auch noch mit drin hast und so ist es ist es mega äh es ist auf jeden Fall,
Es ist nicht ausreichend darüber nachgedacht worden und es ist derzeit einfach sehr schwierig, das zuverlässig zu überprüfen, durch Scannen.
Ja, also irgendwie ein Fleck Booster mit rein zu spezifizieren wäre wahrscheinlich gut gewesen, aber das äh hätten sie Edgie machen müssen. Und es.
Na ja diese die wievielte Impfung das ist, das ist da ja schon drin. Aber äh es wird nicht ange.
Richtig genau, aber du kannst halt nicht sagen, eine eine Dritte ist ein Booster, super, aber eine zweite kann ein Booster sein, wenn die erste Johnson und Johnson ist und ja.
Genau und manchmal haben Leute dann irgendwie das bei manchen wurde ein Zertifikat ausgestellt, wo das dann als Dritte gemacht wurde, wenn du einen Booster auf Johnson und Johnson hat. Bei manchen war's aber der Zweite ist es ein totales Chaos.
Ich war äh letztens äh an einer äh gastronomischen Einrichtung.
Der war auch so ein Impfpass-Checker am Eingang und äh der der hat das eigentlich ganz also er hatte eine lustige also eine eine eine einen ganz netten Workaround weil,
der hat dann einfach unvermittelt gefragt, wann hast Geburtstag? Und das war ich eigentlich auch nicht schlecht
Der hat sich einfach der hat da drauf geguckt, hat dann schön sein Geburtsdatum gesehen und hat dann nicht irgendwie nach Ausweis oder sonst was gefragt, hat einfach nur so unvermittelt, so wann hast du Geburtstag und ähm an der Antwort, ob die Leute halt spontan mal darauf antworten
können sie's natürlich auch, ob sie ähm.
Das ist in der Tat ein guter Tipp. Cool.
Habe ich auch gesagt so, machste gut. I like your thinking, so habe ihm dann gesagt, weil ich Geburtstag habe und hat er äh anerkannt.
Also fand ich, fand ich ganz fand ich ganz gut, ja, so dass mal eben so spontan äh hinzukriegen,
Ja, aber egal, also streng genommen hat der Micha nicht richtig kontrolliert, aber wie dem auch oder ich glaube, ich hatte dem sowieso schon den Ausweis hingehalten oder so.
Das sind natürlich auch die Experten, die sich erst mal von allen denen äh die den die Drei zeigen lassen und dann von allen den Ausweis,
wo ich auch eigentlich gedacht habe, ob ich nicht mal unvermittelt frage so nach welchem Namen suchst du denn jetzt eigentlich gerade? Aber lassen wir das.
Ich glaube, diese ganze Impfpassgeschichte da ist eh also letztendlich würde ich sagen.
Auch da haben die Ärmel schon so ein bisschen Recht behalten, dass jetzt, sage ich mal, so die große Welle,
an den Einlasssituationen ernsthafte Impfpassprüfungen,
weit verbreitet auftreten. Äh das ist einfach nicht der Fall gewesen. Das haben wir auch quasi vorhergesagt, ne.
Hängt so ein bisschen von einem Ort ab. Also es gibt Orte, die machen das sehr nachlässig, es gibt Orte, die machen das sehr gewissenhaft.
Richtig. Aber das meinte ich mit mit in der Breite scheint mir das nicht äh also ist nicht lückenlos, nein.
Definitiv.
Okay ähm.
Lass uns lieber über Sachen reden, über die wir nicht mehr reden wollten.
Ähm ja also ich sage ja so äh,
Ich erinnere mich noch daran, als als diese ganzen Snowden-Enthüllungen waren, da war bei den.
Ähm CC so ein bisschen die Rücksprache, okay, wie gehen wir damit jetzt um? Und wir haben dann so gesagt, so okay, die eine Sache, die wir jetzt nicht machen dürfen, ist sagen, ja? Auch wenn wir's immer gesagt haben,
War klasse, ne? Das wäre einfach jetzt ein kein sinnvoller Beitrag zu dieser,
ähm für diese politischen Gefüge, zu dieser Enthüllung, zu dem was die Menschen jetzt gerade beschäftigt, wäre es jetzt einfach vom CCC kein kein Wertstiftender Beitrag gewesen, zu sagen, hör ich ja immer gesagt,
und ähm deswegen haben wir uns das da verkniffen.
Bei Luca hingegen verkneifen wir das nicht. Weil das haben wir schon immer gesagt,
und äh jetzt äh ist es auch jetzt trifft quasi genau das ein, was wir was sich abzeichnete, schon äh als wir letztes Mal drüber gesprochen haben, äh ging jetzt eine ganz schnelle Welle rum,
Länder äh sagen, wir verlängern die Luca-Verträge nicht. Ja ähm hatten ja angesprochen, die Luca App
als privatwirtschaftliche App hat es ja den den einmaligen Deal bekommen von den Ländern millionenfach
Finanziert er mit Millionen von Euros finanziert zu werden und gleichzeitig in 13 Bundesländern quasi per Verordnung im Prinzip.
Dafür gesorgt wird, dass die Gastronominnen ihre äh Besucher am Eingang zwingen, die Luca Äpp zu installieren. Ähm dadurch eben eine zweistellige Millionenanzahl Nutzer und die Geschichte ist allen bekannt.
Und jetzt gab's eine schöne Frage von
Thilo oder ich weiß gar nicht, ob der die in der Bundespressekonferenz gefragt hat oder äh ich hab's auf jeden Fall auf Twitter zuerst gesehen. Er hat das dann vertwittert, weil er nämlich das BMG gefragt hat als Gesundheitsministerium und meinte zahlt,
Gesundheitsministerium, die Luka Lizenzkosten für die Länder und das Gesundheitsministerium hat gesagt, nee,
Und dann haben die Länder halt so relativ zügig innerhalb der nächsten Tage dann so gesagt ah hm ach so wer ach so müssen wir selber bezahlen? Ja dann äh guck doch nochmal ganz kurz.
Das haben sie auch bisher auch schon getan, die Länder. Also der Bund hat es ja noch nie bezahl.
Es gibt dieses EFA-Prinzip und nachdem hätte,
ist eben wäre es eine Option gewesen, dass das BMG dann eben diese äh äh Luca Verträge zahlt,
Ne, also wenn alle Länder etwas machen oder dann kann eben auch der Bund sagen, okay, dann machen wir jetzt hier einen in einem Abwisch, ja und da diese Option jetzt vom Tisch war.
Ähm ging dann quasi so ein ein Domino los ähm wo.
Immer mehr Länder, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, mit wem das mit welchen Ländern das angefangen hat und was jetzt gerade der Stand ist, aber das würde auch quasi ähm
sagen wir mal, wer will das jetzt hier erzählen, wenn's ein bisschen später hört,
wird es auch wieder sehen also mehr Länder dazukommen und es werden am Ende alle sein, denn jetzt passiert folgendes ähm.
Also ich habe,
chatte darüber mit ein, zwei Leuten und habe gesagt, jetzt wird Folgendes passieren. Luca wird drastisch die Preise senken und die werden's am Ende sogar kostenlos anbieten, ja? Und genau das äh ist jetzt auch passiert, ja? Denn die,
also Luca hat jetzt quasi angekündigt OK dass sie,
ähm diesen Service, der vorher, ich glaube 18.000 Euro im Jahr gekostet hat. Den bieten sie jetzt ähm monatlich kündbar für 750 Euro an.
Pro Gesunde hohen Gesundheitsamt.
Pro Gesundheitsamt, ja um quasi zu sagen, komm, liebe Gesundheitsämter, also ne, mach noch weiter mit, nur bei Bedarf und so weiter und der Hintergrund ist natürlich jetzt relativ einfach. Die wollen oder die müssen.
Die Daseinsberechtigung für diese App aufrechterhalten, ja? Also die werden und da bin ich mir sehr sicher, dass potenziell am Ende oder sie werden's am Ende kostenlos anbieten,
weil sie brauchen ja quasi ihre Daseinsberechtigung um jetzt, ihren Plan B zu verfolgen und auch das haben sie jetzt ähm endlich,
ja zugegeben, dass sie quasi jetzt suchen nach neuen
ähm Möglichkeiten sich stärker als Digitalisierungspartner der Gastronomie und Kulturbranche zu positionieren. Die bisherige Integration von Speisekarten war nur der Anfang
Und das war natürlich das, was sie vor äh vor fast einem Jahr, als der,
CC, die Bundesnotbremse forderte immer äh äh geleugnet haben, obwohl wir ja die internen Präsentationen kannten,
in denen von vielfältigen Businessmöglichkeiten,
schon die Rede war. Ja, das hatten sie ja quasi aus ihren öffentlichen Präsentationen herausgenommen und ähm,
Es gab einmal so ein paar, die zu uns geleakt sind ähm und es gab auch auf frag den Staat dann glaube ich eine Präsentation in der diese ähm,
diese Pläne, die damals schon bestanden, eben auch glasklar dokumentiert waren.
Na ja und das machen sie jetzt auch. Ähm Netzpolitik Org Titel dazu, Luca App will endemisch werden. Ich habe dann auch direkt angemahnt, dass sie äh,
unsere Titel hier nicht klauen sollen, das haben sie von uns. Haben sie behauptet, wüssten sie nicht, habe ich gesagt, Unwissenheit schützt vor Strafe nicht.
Äh ich meine für das Geld, was die haben letztes Jahr über eine Million Euro bekommen, dafür können die sich ja wohl mal ihre eigenen Witze ausdenken. Also finde ich weiß nicht, wie du das siehst, Tim.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall ist dieses ganze Luca-Projekt ist äh komplett äh dabei gegen die Wand zu fahren und äh mit Ansage und das ist schon jetzt wirklich ein bisschen,
Sagen schon ein bisschen lächerlich äh das mit anzusehen. Ey Leute, ich mache euch halbe Preis.
Ist auch krass, ja, dass die jetzt also.
Lauf nicht weg.
Also dieser Ablauf in in in irgendwie in wie Kürze wie wie schnell dieses Domino ging, weißt du wieso ja ja verlängert ihr und äh BMG sagt nö machen also bunt halt schon mal nicht, Länder oh dann oh dann brauchen wir glaube ich auch nicht mehr und
dann fangen sie an so mit ey okay komm hier ein Huni, ein Uni und wie gesagt ich sage dir, die machen's am Ende kostenlos, ja und dann werden sie versuchen sich dafür zu feiern
und dann sehen sie halt zu, dass sie noch schnell also Hauptsache das Ding muss weiter genutzt werden, ne. Das ist ja jetzt quasi da schwimmen denen ja jetzt gerade die Felle weg,
und ja, wir haben es von vornherein gesagt und es ist dokumentiert und hier sage ich mit vollem äh mit voller Freude äh ja.
Na ja. Also wie viele Bundesländer haben jetzt na ja reicht jetzt auch,
damit sagen. Ähm.
Drei Bundesländer haben jetzt, glaube ich, schon gesagt, dass sie das nicht machen wollen, zähle ich gerade richtig, Schleswig-Holstein auf jeden Fall und ähm der Rest wird gemunkelt, ne.
Nee, das sind mehr. Ich gucke mal gerade ähm also auf Luca Punkt Fail äh.
Ah, das ist alles schön zusammengefasst.
Das ist also da ist äh grün,
Also Grün sind Thüringen, Sachsen und Nordrhein-Westfalen. Die hatten nämlich keinen Vertrag gekündigt, haben Bremen, Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, Schleswig-Holstein ähm ah erst recht.
Ist es nur drei? Im im Saarland wird geprüft, Brandenburg wird
Brandenburg wird geprüft, aber genau, die genau, hier ist es nicht. Äh Kündigung absehbar, also in SR ist die also im Saarland ist die Kündigung absehbar, Brandenburg ist die Kündigung ähm absehbar.
In Berlin ist die Kündigung absehbar und äh Bayern, Niedersachsen, Hessen und Rheinland-Pfalz,
sowie Sachsen-Anhalt, da sind die Verträge noch aktiv. Hamburg auch aber ja, das geht jetzt so weiter.
Also vor allem niemand hat bisher verlängert. Das ist,
Und ich glaube, das wird auch jetzt relativ schnell gehen, weil äh es eh klar ist, dass diese ganze Nummer mit,
Kontakt aufschreiben und Kontaktverfolgung der Gesundheitsämter ey das funktioniert schon so lange, äh nicht mehr und ist mit OmiCroin jetzt so dermaßen hinfällig geworden.
Das also es war schon immer eine eine unsinnige Idee und äh.
Also nicht schon immer es war schon immer eine gute Idee äh zu Zeiten, wo wir nicht Corona hatten und es war am Anfang
auch eine gute Idee, nur haben wir ja gesehen, wie langsam das alles lief und die Corona-Warn-App war eigentlich von Anfang an die einzige richtige Idee,
und äh man hat sich eigentlich mit diesem ganzen Luca-Theater die Gelegenheit verschenkt,
die App äh in der Hinsicht nochmal richtig zu pushen und zu verbreiten. Man sieht ja jetzt, wie wie die funktioniert, wie viele Warnungen die rausschickt,
ja und hätte ja keiner ahnen können, dass das auch äh wirklich mal funktioniert. Na ja und jetzt,
wär's einfach politisch überhaupt nicht zu halten, äh das noch zu verlängern. Ich denke, das wird sich jetzt rumsprechen. Jetzt muckeln sie alle noch ein bisschen rum. Bis Ende Februar haben sie Zeit äh nein zu sagen, sonst werden sie sicherlich.
Ich glaube das einzige Ding ist, dass die wahrscheinlich alle jetzt grade mit Omicron zu Hause sitzen und wahrscheinlich deswegen sieht man in die Abo-Falle. Das wäre das Einzige, was ich mir jetzt noch vorstellen könnte wie irgendjemand da noch.
Installiert euch mal Abo-Alarm und dann geht das schon.
Ja, es ist erstaunlich, also äh wenn man sich anschaut, ne, dass da wirklich schon also,
Von vornherein haben wir gesagt, hier, die werden das nachher auf anderen Wegen monetarisieren und jetzt leiten sie's halt auch ein. Haben sie die ganze Zeit geleugnet und jetzt geht es auf einmal ganz rucki zucki. Na ja, haben wir Recht gehabt.
Wie wie immer. Okay, kommen wir zu interessanteren Themen.
Genau, weil äh man sieht ja, ne, also äh so im Bereich der Telekommunikation braucht der Bund ähm immer noch so ein bisschen Nachhilfe, ne? Gibt's durchaus Dienstleistungsbedarf.
Sehr gute Überleitung.
Ja und äh jetzt müssen wir eine eine Story erzählen, die sich in den letzten Wochen da abgespielt hat, die die irgendwie noch nicht so richtig zu Ende ist. Man weiß auch noch nicht so ganz genau, was dabei rauskommt, aber es ist auf jeden Fall sinnlos.
Wir hatten sie ja schon ein paar Mal äh erwähnt, die ist ja derzeit sehr sehr umtriebig dabei äh alle so ein bisschen zu zu ärgern mit ihren Aktivitäten und sie baut schon seit längerem,
ein äh Tool um mal so äh an diesem Traum der Maschinen lesbaren Regierung weiterzuarbeiten, Abteilung
Wollen jetzt mal wissen, woraus unser Staat eigentlich so besteht. Äh sie hat sich halt sehr darüber beklagt, dass es keine ordentlichen Maschinen lesbare Struktur aller Behörden und Zusammenhänge und zuständigen Personen gibt,
Es gibt so diese ganzen Organigramme, die dann immer veröffentlicht werden. So hier ein PDF da einen PNG und äh dann kann man sich das alles von Hand zusammensuchen, aber wie wir ja wissen, äh man braucht so was in maschinenlesbarer Form,
halt auch mal strategisch abklappern kann und dass man einfach diese Informationen zum Beispiel in Apps ja auch äh schnell mal eben zur Verfügung stellen kann, wenn man,
passender Ansprechpartner, passende Behörden sucht, äh Adressen, Telefonnummern, Kontakte, alles mögliche, E-Mail-Adressen, Webseiten,
Also baut sie an diesem Tool und liest so alles aus, was irgendwie da ist. Sagt sie.
Sucht quasi nach Daten, wo dieser Staat ordentlich beschrieben ist und hat auch das ein oder andere gefunden und bringt das jetzt in so eine neue Struktur. Und dabei,
viele dann eine ja eine Behörde oder ein ja ein Teil des Staates auf,
der da aufgeführt wird unter dem schönen Titel Bundesservice Telekommunikation. Hatte sie noch nie von gehört. Äh,
auch nicht und es findet sich da auch eine Selbstbeschreibung, die liest sich ganz toll, ich lese das mal vor.
Die Behörde ist Dienstleister des Bundes. Sie nimmt verschiedene Aufgaben ausschließlich für die Bundesministerien und ihre Geschäftsbereiche wahr. Dazu gehören Fachaufgaben, Querschnitts- und Unterstützungsaufgaben sowie Modernisierungshilfen. Mhm, sind ja interessant.
Was das so sein könnte. Und jetzt jetzt jetzt müsst ihr euch irgendwie mal so vorstellen, ihr hättet jetzt so einen Flyer von irgend so einem neuen Start-up in der Hand. So liest sich das so ein bisschen,
ihren breit gefächerten Fachaufgaben setzt die BST die Vorgaben der Ressorts administrativ um,
die BST übernimmt im Bereich der Telekommunikation eine Scharnierfunktion. Ziel ist es, die komplexen Arbeitsabläufe effizienter zu gestalten und mit einer weitreichenden Bündelung eine Kostenersparnis zu erzielen.
Die Bearbeitung von Querschnittsaufgaben wie die Zahlbarmachung von Verwaltungsaufgaben Kosten und Kommunikationsmanagement,
unterstützt die BST die Konzentration der Bundesbehörden auf ihre Kernaufgaben und leistet einen nachhaltigen Beitrag zur Qualitätssteigerung.
Die BST ist intensiv in den Prozess zur Neuformierung der Behördenkooperation eingebunden. Die Modernisierungshilfen der BST
Andere Bundesbehörden durch Beratungs, Coachings und Evaluierungsleistungen sind Impulsgeber eines modernen Verwaltungsmanagements auf den Gebieten der Kommunikations- und Digitaltechnik.
Kommunikations- und Informationstechnik ist Motor der Modernisierung, die BST steht für eine weitere Professionalisierung und Stanalisierung innerhalb der Bundesverwaltung oder denkt man sich dann,
hurra, endlich geil, super. Warum haben wir davon noch nie was mitbekommen,
Nicht, dass hier irgendjemand konkret wird, was die jetzt eigentlich wirklich machen.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall hat sie sich da sehr drüber gewundert und ähm tatsächlich wird diese ähm dieses ja Behörde,
Wurde ja hier die Selbstbeschreibung, dass es sich hier um eine Behörde handelt. Äh dieser Dienstleister wird auch auf Service Punkt DE oder beziehungsweise wurde auf Service Punkt Bund DE auch aufgeführt mit einer Adresse in Berlin.
Uns stellt sie auch raus, dass auch Frag den Staat hier schon mal was Ähnliches probiert haben vor äh zehn Jahren äh auch schon mal so eine Liste bekommen haben, wo auch diese Agentur oder ich sage jetzt Agentur, also diese.
BST aufgeführt war,
ohne weitere äh Erläuterung. Ja und da steht da auch eine Telefonnummer, angerufen. Geht keiner ran. Sonst gibt's nur eine Faxnummer. Okay, E-Mail probieren, gibt's Poststelle at BST Punkt Bund DE.
Ja, steht da so. Kann nicht zugestellt werden. Echt geil.
Auf Twitter rumgefragt, sag mal wer kennt denn das irgendwie und dann nur äh Grillen zirpen. Niemand hatte jemals was von gehört. Aber dann läuft ein Typ
zu dieser Adresse in Berlin, Heidelberger Straße irgendwas und findet tatsächlich einen Briefkasten mit dem Namen
Bundesservice Telekommunikation drauf, sonst gar nix, kein Emblem, kein hier ist eine Behörde, hier ist sowas Wichtiges, hier geht's rein oder so, sondern einfach nur so ein Briefkasten, wo das so drauf geschrieben ist und es sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so
also wenn wenn hier so äh.
Die politische Schönheit oder Peng oder so so eine Aktion machen würden, weil's einfach mal so einen Briefkastenadresse zu schaffen, so. So sieht das so ein bisschen aus. Vielleicht ist das ja auch so. Wer weiß.
Stellst du eine Informationsanfrage eines Bundesverwaltungsamts ja, weil die ja da irgendwie äh meinen, dass es das gibt.
Und dann so ja nee äh
Können aber jetzt hier äh also es war eine Informations also eine IFG-Anfrage, ne und dann haben sie das irgendwie so wie so eine Bürgeranfrage behandelt und so, ja nee, da müssen sie schon bei den richtigen Stellen nachfragen und so. Also sie haben sich überhaupt nicht so verhalten, wie man sich auf so eine Informationsanfrage äh zu verhalten hat, weil es ja ein formaler,
berechtigte Nachfrage ist, die dann entsprechend bedient werden soll und dann äh ruft sie da noch mal an und dann.
Äh werden die schon kriegen die schon so ein bisschen Muffinsausen hat man so den Eindruck so ja nee da ist was schief gelaufen und sie kriegen ja nochmal eine Antwort und so weiter kriegt dann aber dann so eine Antwort wo so drin steht eine eingehende Prüfung der Aktenlage ergab
die Kommunikation mit der Bundesservice Telekommunikation beziehungsweise etwaige Unterlagen bezogen auf den erfolgten Eintrag auf den Bundesportalservice Bund DE
nicht Gegenstand, hiesig geführter Vorgänge geworden sind. Interessantes Deutsch,
Kurz darauf wird dieser Eintrag auf Service Bunt DE gelöscht. Dafür gibt's diese Mailadresse auf einmal,
Auch geil. So und dann gibt's eine Bundestagsabgeordnete, die dann einfach so eine äh mal eine Anfrage gestellt hat. Das darf man ja, wenn man im Bundestag ist. Da muss dann nämlich die Bundesregierung innerhalb von acht Tagen äh antworten.
Und dann war die Frage so ein bisschen so formuliert mit äh welche Mittel hat denn diese äh dieser Bundesservice Telekommunikation in den letzten fünf Jahren bekommen? Da kam so die Antwort sehr in den letzten fünf Jahren haben sie nichts bekommen.
Nochmal die Frage neu formuliert und dann so.
Heidi Reicheneck oder ein Mitarbeiter von Heidi Reicheneck, weil du sagst, das ist so eine Bundestagsabgeordnete, die können wir dann schon mal benennen.
Von den Linken. Genau. Die haben's äh die genau. Können wir benennen und ähm hat dann noch mal konkretisiert und dann war die Aussage mit ja nee, die haben noch nie ein Budget bekommen. So oh geil.
In den letzten Jahren, in den letzten Jahren ja.
Ja, die erste Anfrage war nach den letzten fünf Jahren und danach meinten sie auch über diesen Zeitraum hinaus. Also das heißt halt so viel wie nie, ne. Also wenn man eine Bundesbehörde, die den geilsten Scheiß macht,
kostenlos.
Gut ey.
Hat sie alle Lösungen hat, ja? Also die äh schlagen nochmal nach. Also die Zahlbarmachung von Verwaltungsaufgaben.
Ja und vor allem, wie geil das Ganze halt ohne E-Mail, ne, also so weit vorne. Ich meine, wir wollen ja alle E-Mail loswerden.
Weißt du, weißt du, wie sie das machen.
Nullruten. Die.
Blocktsche.
Über die Blockchain.
Die haben noch die haben doch fünf Blockchains aufgesetzt und machen das da rüber. Und hier schickt noch E-Mails, sag mal, lebt ihr denn im 21. Jahrhundert oder was?
Also die Nummer ist wirklich skurril irgendwie. Dann hat jetzt Thilo Jung heute auf der Bundespressekonferenz, als das Innenministerium darum saß, mal nachgefragt, so was denn irgendwie mit dieser Behörde wäre und dann meinten die so, ja nee, im Geschäftsbereich des BMI
gibt es keine Behörde mit dem Namen Bundesservice Telekommunikation.
Also super fischi, irgendwie keiner weiß, was es damit auf sich hat. Seit zehn Jahren mindestens zehn Jahren wird die als Existent gelistet, hat nie Geld bekommen. Beschreibt sich selber in den höchsten Tönen, dass sie irgendwie alle Probleme der Zukunft löst und
keiner kann da anrufen.
Und da ist natürlich naheliegend so was Schönes hatten wir zuletzt mit dem Institut.
Genau, kann nämlich gut sein, dass es sich hier einfach um irgend so eine weitere Tarnorganisation irgendeines Geheimdienstes äh handelt.
Und wenn man jetzt äh sich überlegt, dass es ähm also wenn das BMI sagt, haben wir nichts mit zu tun, dann bleibt eigentlich nur noch der BND.
Der BND äh unterliegt eben eigentlich auf direktem Kanzleramt und damit würde,
Das äh irgendwie halbwegs passen, ja. Ähm nur.
Der BND hatte 20013 nach den Snowen-Enthüllungen gesagt, dass er seine Außenstellen enttarnen würde. Ja und,
Äh Ströbele, Hans-Christian Ströbele, hatte auch schon irgendwie gesagt, ja das ist irgendwie nicht so wirklich passiert. Ähm
und der BND hat offenbar so vermutet, Lilit jetzt, äh diejenigen enttarnt, von denen sowieso schon bekannt war, dass sie zum DND gehörten, zum Beispiel eben hier das das bekannte Ionosphäreninstitut.
Ja und tja offenbar oder so ist jetzt hier die die ähm Vermutung.
Ist eben diese äh Service-Wundestelle Telekommunikationsservice oder was halt eine.
Bundesservice Telekommunikation eine äh Tarnorganisation eines Geheimdienstes also vermutlich dann eben,
ähm.
BNDs oder des Terrorabwährtszentrums, denn ich habe gerade überlegt, Heidelberger Straße kenne ich doch, das ist ein Treptow. Das ist nicht weit vom Terrorabwehrzentrum.
Das ist da direkt um die Ecke. Also es ist irgendwie wird immer vier, fünf Straßen weiter, also,
kommst über die ähm die Elsenstraße.
Dann hast du ja rechts das Terrorabwehrzentrum und dann kurz darauf kreuzt so die Heidelberger Straße.
Ja, ja, ist umme Ecke. In so einem Wohngebiet.
Also das ist das ist das ist unglaublich.
Also äh wir wissen jetzt noch nicht ganz genau, was man daraus machen kann. Das ist auch so ein Wohngebäude, so ein ganz normales fünfstöckiges.
Mietgebäude ist das irgendwie also wirklich. Mofischi geht's irgendwie echt gar nicht.
JK ist der Follower, der da hingegangen ist äh sagt er auch also irgendwie hier so dieses Amtsschild äh fehlt leider ne also normalerweise hast du ja so ein Ätlerchen irgendwo an eine eine Gebäude gemacht wenn das.
Irgendwas ist ja.
Wenn wir damit angeben wollen, ne.
Tja.
Die sind halt komplett virtualisiert. Die machen das halt äh die sind eine Cloud und so. Orchestration.
Pulsgeber eines modernen Verwaltungsmanagements. Äh so oder so,
sieht man mal, was es bringen kann, wenn man mal sich wirklich um die Maschinen-Days Bar
der Bundesregierung bemüht. Insofern ein sehr lobenswertes Projekt, was äh Limited da an Start gebracht hat und äh ich hoffe, das wird noch weitere Erkenntnisse äh liefern. Mittlerweile streiten sich der Wikipedia darüber, ob's dafür einen Eintrag geben sollte für eine Behörde, von der dementiert wird, dass es sie gibt,
in der Löschdiskussion hat dann irgendjemand glaube Matthias Schindler so schön zusammengefasst so wie na ja also äh die ist auf jeden Fall relevant. Wir wissen bloß noch nicht warum.
Das trifft's eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja Matthias Schickler ist da immer sehr treffsicher in solchen Assessments.
Gut, kommen wir vom Bundesservice Telekommunikation zum Flyerservice Hahn, der ja auch eine ähnliche Daseinsberechtigung hat.
Stimmt, wahrscheinlich sitzt hier wohl jetzt irgendjemand beim ZPS und sagt, oh Mann, ey, wir haben uns jahrelang vorbereitet. Wir waren schon in den.
Wir waren schon in den offiziellen Listen. Ey wir haben hier irgendwie die komplette Regierung unterwandert und dann kommt irgendeiner und googelt.
Oh das.
Das ist ja super, oder?
Und ich kann ja mal beim ZPS fragen, aber ich glaube, die haben grade andere Sorgen, als dass ihnen ihre nächste Aktion,
ein Superding, wenn die jetzt irgendwann so von Peng oder ZPS jemand kommt und sagt so, oh Mann, ey, Scheiße, das ist jahrelang vorbereitet.
ZPS, mehrere Privatwohnungen von Mitgliedern des Zentrums für politische Schönheit wurden durchsucht.
Und zwar,
im Rahmen von potenziellen Strafermittlungen. Äh wir haben ja hier über die Aktion des Flyer Service Hahn berichtet. Der Flyer Service Hahn hat,
von wurde von vielen,
Kreisverbänden der AfD beauftragt, deren Flyer zu verteilen, was üblicherweise in Parteien die äh Parteisoldaten machen, aber,
ähm in der AFD wollte man halt lieber den Flyer Service Hahn beauftragen, das zu tun, weil man unter den eigenen Leuten jetzt niemanden motivieren konnte.
Und der Flyerservice Hahn hat sich dann die Flyer zuschicken lassen und ist dann allerdings in Terminschwierigkeiten geraten, die noch ähm,
pünktlich zuzustellen. Ja, so dass dann eben weiß ich nicht wie viele Tonnen das waren,
an AfD-Flyern nicht äh die die Menschen erreicht haben. Die haben dann übrigens die im weiteren Verlauf ja noch mal ausgestellt. Da konnte man ja dadrin baden und so, ne, konntest du dir das alles angucken und dann haben sie die ähm.
In seiner Papiervernichtungsrecyclinganlage quasi schreddern lassen und daraus wird dann so ein ähm ja wie so Füllmaterial für Kartons.
Ähm und,
Ich habe tatsächlich auch getwittert ähm eine solche quasi diese geschredderten Flyer in der Hand voll davon in so einem äh ja wie nennt man das Einmachglas,
äh geschenkt bekommen zu Weihnachten, äh wo dann noch so ein Aufkleber drauf ist. Wir wünschen alles Gute, Flyerservice Hahn.
Der der Link ist in den kannst du dir mal anschauen. Das war mein Weihnachtsgeschenk vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit. Natürlich ein äh Kunstwerk von äh,
Also davon NFT, Tim, ne? Meinst du, was der bringt auf auf auf äh auf auf a Blockcha.
Ne?
Geht noch was.
Äh genau, also das das da haben diese AFD-Flyer ihre Bestimmung gefunden? Und ähm.
Genau. Jetzt äh wir haben ja als wir von dieser Aktion berichtet haben äh darüber gesprochen, dass quasi,
Die Frage ist, wird jetzt die AfD ähm ein Strafverfahren daraus anstrengen?
Und ist das klug oder ist das dumm? Ja oder ist das einfach für beide Seiten ähm vielleicht potenziell von,
von Vorteil für ihre Botschaft, wenn die AfD das tut. Und das war ja, als er im Prinzip eine spannende Frage, ne, also die AFD könnte dann halt quasi so Trump Style irgendwie so eine ähm.
Legende von der gestohlenen Wahl aufrechterhalten, was Sie sicherlich interessiert,
das Zentrum für politische Schönheit kriegt jedes Mal wieder Aufmerksamkeit und es sieht wohl danach aus ähm,
dass die AfD das getan hat, denn hier finden jetzt also Ermittlungen statt wegen dieser Aktion und deswegen auch die,
Hausdurchsuchung und eben Durchsuchungsbeschluss steht. Ziel des Beschuldigten und seiner Mittäter war es dabei
Gliederung der Parteialternative für Deutschland sowie dieser Angehörige Einzelpersonen zur Übersendung von Wahlflyern zu veranlassen,
Indem Sie mit diesen zum Schein, deren endgeldliche Verteilung vereinbarten. Tatsächlich war die Verteilung der Flyer C noch zu keinem Zeitpunkt beabsichtigt. Vielmehr kam es dem Beschuldigten und seinen Mittätern darauf an,
Die Flyer jedenfalls bis nach der Wahl des 20. Deutschen Bundestages am 26. September 221 zu behalten und so eine Verteilung
zu verhindern. Und ich hatte ja spekuliert in der Sendung,
man das nicht darf, dass das verboten sein könnte.
Was? Meinst du.
Ich hatte ich habe mich mal weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt und da hatte ich nicht so recht, weil äh tatsächlich ist es offenbar äh gar nicht so oder ist es hier jetzt nicht so leicht gewesen ähm denen einen,
quasi etwas zu finden, was sie ähm falsch gemacht haben.
Und der Paragraph, der ihnen äh hier vorgeworfen wird, ist,
der Paragraph 269 StTGB Fälschung, Beweis erheblicher Daten.
Wer zu Täuschung im Rechtsverkehr, Beweis erhebliche Daten so speichert oder verändert, dass bei ihrer Wahrnehmung eine unechte oder,
verfälschte Urkunde vorliegen würde oder derart,
speicherte oder veränderte Daten gebraucht wird mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu fünf Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe bestraft. Versuche es strafbar und so weiter und jetzt fragst du dich was ist das für ein komischer äh Paragraf? Wann ist der denn erfüllt?
Und der kommt beispielsweise bei Phishing Straftaten zum Tragen. Also quasi die werden jetzt äh oder sollen verfolgt werden mit den gleichen rechtlichen Paragraphen, die beim Phishing,
ähm zum Tragen kämen. Ähm.
Tatsächlich rechnen rechnet niemand dem äh tatsächlichen Verfahren eine äh einen Erfolg aus,
die Anwälte des ZPS sagen
äh das wirkt vorgeschoben. Die Vorwürfe reichen vermutlich nicht mal für eine Klageerhebung. Ähm es geht hier eigentlich um einen politischen Skandal. Die wollten die halt durchsuchen. Wir rufen die gesamte Zivilgesellschaft dazu auf,
Diesen Angriff,
auf die Kunstfreiheit abzuwehren und äh Stefan Pälzer vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit sagte äh hier ist ein einfach auch nur ein Vorwand sein mit diesem Verfahren kann der Staatsschutz unsere Strukturen,
und gleichzeitig versuchen uns einzuschüchtern. Die Ermittlungen sind politisch motiviert, begruhnen auf
völlig fadenscheinigen Begründungen. Statt endlich gegen Rechtsextremisten durchzugreifen, bricht die Berliner Polizei offensichtlich mit Rückendeckung des neuen Senats in unsere Wohnungen ein. Wir werten die Durchsuchung als Angriff,
auf das Grundrecht auf Kunstfreiheit. Dann wurden ihnen noch äh siebenundvierzig Feuerzeuge weggenommen.
Was mit Flyer, Service.
Ja, die wird fleißig hart bedruckt sind und,
Das ist natürlich auch also äh bei der Beschlagnahme wurde ihnen quasi schon in Aussicht gestellt, dass sie die nicht wiederkriegen wegen Gefährdung mit anderen Worten wer und ich hab's nicht gemacht, als es sie damals zu kaufen gab, habe ich gedacht, ach Feuerzeug,
bin nicht Rauch aber Feuerzeug. Ich habe ein Käppi gekauft, ne und ähm ja jetzt sind's die Feuerzeuge, die halt äh auf dem Kunstmarkt.
Ja. Ja, also das ZPS sieht es ähm äh halbwegs mit Humor, aber natürlich trotzdem,
man sich dagegen wehren, weil also es ist natürlich hier bisschen also denen wurde ein Computer weggenommen, Telefone weggenommen, ne. Also man man lacht dann immer so über Hausdurchsuchungen, aber Hausdurchsuchungen willste nicht.
Nervt deine Computer und alles, was die mitnehmen, ist Ewigkeiten weg,
ähm kannst du also ja in den Fällen dann halt neu kaufen, ne und das ist äh alles nicht ähm.
Nicht schön. Ja, also so sehr wir da jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen drüber scherzen und das ZPS natürlich auch, sagen wir mal, aus einem,
aus einem Holz geschnitzt ist, was äh äh eine gewisse Resilienz gegen so etwas hat,
jetzt ne vielleicht ausreichend juristische Unterstützung ist das trotzdem ne sind solche Dinger Dinge immer,
ewig nervend. Die beschäftigen dich, die beschäftigen die Anwälte und ja, das ist ein äh Problem.
Gucken wir mal, wie das ausgeht.
Ansonsten genau nur äh um hinterzugehen, also es ist die Strafanzeige der AfD und äh die äh das ZPS kritisiert. Das Gericht scheint dem Durchsuchungsbeschluss schlichtweg die Strafanzeige der AfD ohne weitere Ermittlungstätigkeit oder rechtliche,
Abwägung oder Prüfung zugrunde gelegt zu haben.
Also genau, man kann natürlich das ZPS mit Spenden unterstützen. Die werden jetzt Kosten haben und ich denke äh um hier diese ähm ja den den,
Bei solchen Sachen muss man natürlich dann eben die Stärke auch zeigen, die Kunstfreiheit verteidigen, diese Aktion verteidigen, damit ein,
auch weiterhin Leute halt den Mut hm zu solchen Aktionen aufbringen, ne.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
72 Tonnen waren das.
Also ich find's bemerkenswert, dass sie ähm dass sie jetzt wirklich da über diese Urkunden also es ist ja so Urkundenddelikt ne dieser dieser Paragraph.
Ja ja es ist ähm also vor allem na vermutlich also mein mein ich versteh's jetzt auch nicht so ganz, aber meine Vermutung ist, dass sie ähm.
Also eigentlich hätte ich ja jetzt vermutet,
dass ähm wenn du jemandem sagst, ich verteile deine Flyer und erkennbar ist, dass du das nie wirklich beabsichtigt hast, äh das eigentliche Ermittlungen wegen Betrug geht, aber das hat eben die äh eine Sprecherin der Generalstaatsanwaltschaft auch bestätigt,
weil die ähm das ZPS hat von der AFD kein Geld äh.
Angenommen. Ja, also die haben denen keine Rechnung geschrieben und die haben.
Ne? Geschlossen.
Ob ob es einen Vertrag war oder nicht kann man glaube ich drüber streiten, aber hier die also sie haben kein Geld von denen genommen. Sie haben den sogar auch angeboten, die Flyer zurückzugeben.
Also kurz vor der Bundestagswahl.
Großartig.
Und deswegen gab's halt hier keine Aneignungsabsicht. Ja, also die haben ja quasi die haben weder die Flyer behalten noch das Geld und deswegen.
Stehe. Wir haben jetzt sozusagen Schwierigkeiten, den richtigen Paragrafen zu finden und probieren's jetzt einfach mal damit mal. Das ist ja wirklich.
So, ja? Und da ist aber jetzt die Sache bei klassischen Betrugshandlungen im Internet, die mit diesem Paragraphen üblicherweise einhergehen, sind,
nicht unüblich, sagt hier die äh gute Sprecherin der Generalstaatsanwaltschaft. Nur dass es in diesem Fall eben keinen Betrug gab, sondern nur die Vortäuschung einer Nichtsexistenten,
Firma. Also es ist juristisch ein bisschen interessant und ähm.
Ja ich beiße mir hier so ein bisschen auf die Zunge, weil ich äh nicht weiß, ob alle Informationen öffentlich sind, aber in dem Moment,
also das ZPS hat schon so ein bisschen, das ist jetzt kein Zufall, ne, dass die,
eben angeboten haben die Flyer zurückzugeben und auch kein Geld genommen haben und so, ne? Es ist ja nicht so, als hätten die jetzt zum ersten Mal äh.
Sich was.
Mit Anwälten Kontakt. Ja. Die werden sich schon ähm informiert haben.
Und äh sie wurden jetzt zum Beispiel auch nicht abgemahnt, ja weil,
könnte sein, dass sie vielleicht schon erklärt haben, dass sie schon dass sie es unterlassen werden in Zukunft oder so, ne.
Ist auf jeden Fall ein ist es äh auf jeden Fall ein guter Hack. So, das kann man glaube ich mal festhalten.
Das war ein ein guter Hack. Ähm ja also äh trotzdem diese Durchsuchung,
unverhältnismäßig, weil, ne, ich meine, es ist ein relativ klarer Sachverhalt, ja und da brauchst du jetzt auch nicht mehr noch irgendwelche Beweise für, weil das ZPS hat ja umfangreich,
quasi gestanden, was sie getan haben, ja? Du kannst dir ein dreiviertel Stunde Video angucken, wo sie sich erklären und dann haben wir das gemacht und dann haben wir das gemacht, dann haben wir das gemacht, so eine ist jetzt irgendwie so die können das ja jetzt nicht mehr leugnen, ja so und,
ganz im Gegenteil. So und insofern denen jetzt die Computer wegzunehmen und so äh würde mich schon.
Würde ich mich schon fragen, wie man das jetzt ähm verargumentieren möchte.
Ja, das könnte auch noch mal interessant werden.
Und ich gehe auch davon aus, dass das PS das klären lassen wird. Vorsichtige.
Mhm. Was bei mir auch gut vorstellen.
Das finde ich mal verboten, ja.
Ja, ach wie dumm auch von der Polizei. Stell dir mal vor, die würden jetzt selber mal gerne ein paar Flyer verteilt wissen und so, die kommen doch bei denen nicht mehr durch.
Indem das System der doch gar nicht an.
Scheint auch äh aber das ist natürlich bei Durchsuchungen äh immer so. Ähm.
Nicht notwendigerweise hast du dann da also sage ich mal sind die Polizistinnen oder Polizisten, die da vor Ort sind.
Der Ansicht, dass das, was sie da gerade tun, äh zielführend oder sinnvoll ist, ne. Also das äh kann man jetzt sage ich mal so.
Na ja, ist halt angeordnet. Die müssen halt äh.
Klar, also ich meine, die ausführenden Polizisten betrifft das jetzt nicht, sondern die anordnender Ebene, so.
Die anordnende Ebene muss sich da schon mal irgendwie an Kopp packen. Andererseits äh sage ich mal.
Kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass jetzt, sage ich mal, die Generalstaatsanwältin oder wer auch immer das jetzt da am Ende dann eingeleitet hat, sich auch gefragt hat, na ja.
Wenn jetzt hier der Verdacht im Raume steht,
ähm dass eine politische Partei hier geschädigt wurde oder so was, dann will ich mir ja nicht vorwerfen lassen, ich hätte nicht alles versucht, um den Sachverhalt aufzuklären.
Also die durch die Wohnung ist ja sowieso in einem durchsuchungsbereiten Zustand vorzuhalten und ähm insofern so.
Auch nicht so viel gefunden habe. Aber immerhin, ich meine ja mit ein paar Feuerzeuge ist auch schon mal gut. Beim Gegensatz zu dir rauchen die, aber der Polizei schon, auch ab und zu habe ich gesehen.
Das also wer demnächst irgendwo ein Polizist mit so einem Flyerservice Hahn Feuerzeug sieht, ne.
Da wisst ihr Bescheid.
Wie er wie sich da mit seinen Joint anmacht. Also da würde ich dann schon mal nachfragen, wo das denn alles herkommt.
Okay, kommen wir äh es gab noch ähm hm,
Woanders ähm äh Hausdurchsuchung, nämlich in Russland. Ähm und zwar,
haben wir ja,
habe ich ja hier schon öfter über Gruppen gesprochen und es gibt ja auch diesen Vortrag von mir, ähm ich glaube hier in der Hacken war das, wo ich äh von meinen Erfahrungen mit äh Gandcrab der Rainsommergruppe gesprochen habe.
Und ich habe auch äh haben wir auch hier darüber gesprochen, dass es eben eine der großen äh Hackergruppen äh Revival also RE,
VIL. Ähm,
aus Russland gelungen ist, verschiedene recht große, spektakuläre Rain Soway-Angriffe zu machen, unter anderem.
Den auf Casaia
ähm also auf diesen Infrastructure ist es Service-Anbieter oder was weiß irgendein Asso-Service-Anbieter, wo dann auch mal kurz hier die schwedische Supermarktkette Coop,
Tag zu machen musste, weil ihre Kassensysteme da dranhängen.
Und daraufhin hatte äh Biden äh ja sich sehr äh unglücklich gezeigt und hatte dann, glaube ich, in diesem Kontext auch äh war ja auch dieser Colonia Pipeline-Hack und so und er hat dann irgendwann mal gesagt, hör mal,
Wir schließen nicht aus, dass wir auf diese Sachen vielleicht auch potenziell mal militärisch reagieren.
Was ja eigentlich nur ein Ausdruck der eigenen Handlungsunfähigkeit ist und haben aber auch diplomatischen Druck auf äh Russland gemacht und haben gesagt, Leute,
wollen, dass ihr da mal, dass ihr die verfolgt, ne. Und der Inlandsgeheimdienst FSB hat an,
14 Wohnorten,
in Russland offenbar Durchsuchungen gemacht, Geld und Ausrüstung beschlagnahmt, 4,8 Millionen Euro direkt sichergestellt, Teil davon in Kryptowährungen,
100.000 US-Dollar und Euro in bar, Computerausrüstung und 20 teure Autos.
Und jetzt hat da also Russland mal äh Strafverfolgung gegen diese Gruppen eingeleitet. Es war ja so.
Dass die Gruppen eigentlich schon inzwischen auch dafür bekannt sind, ich hätte es in dem Vortrag damals glaube ich äh,
als einer der ersten so auch mal dargestellt, dass sie ähm russische Ziele, strategisch nicht angreifen.
Und zum Beispiel in ihrer Software so was haben, wie wenn koryllisches Keyboard eingestellt ist, äh lieber erstmal nix kaputt machen und äh was ich da ja berichtet habe, war der Fall, wo wir,
angefangen haben mit den russisch russisch zu sprechen und die dann auf einmal sehr freundlich wurden und äh,
sagten hör mal, wenn du Russisch bist, ne, dann zeig mal kurz deinen Pass, dann stellen wir dir die Daten kostenlos wieder her.
Und die Motivation ist natürlich hier nicht notwendigerweise ein besonderer Patriotismus, sondern dass sie wissen, wenn sie diese Straftat,
in der in der juristischen Juristiction begehen, dass sie sich da ein paar,
Leute in auf den Radar von ein paar Leuten gelangen, auf deren Radar sie nicht sein wollen, während wenn sie international agieren äh sage ich mal die russischen Interessen nur partiell tangiert werden. Tja
Offenbar waren die jetzt ausreichend tangiert und es ist offenbar eine ähm.
Es hat offenbar eine Verfolgung hier stattgefunden und die USA und Russland streben nun gemeinsam eine bessere Cyber-Sicherheit.
Interessant, weil wir ja auch gleichzeitig wissen, nicht Thema dieser Sendung, dass äh Russland und die USA grade in NATO-Fragen sich gar nicht so grün sind,
ähm entsprechend ja Interessantes geschehen ist, was hier äh passiert ist.
Ja, also zeigt zumindest, dass auch Russland jetzt da nicht unbedingt ähm,
Also wenn das jetzt auch wirklich diese Gruppe war und das alles so stimmt, weiß ich nicht ganz genau, wie zuverlässig jetzt diese Berichte sind, aber gehen wir mal davon aus, dann äh äh zeigt das, dass das jetzt auch,
durchaus auch innerhalb Russlands kein Kavaliersdelikt ist, sondern,
auch nicht unbedingt von allen. Hat unbedingt haben immer den Personalausweis zeigen lassen beziehungsweise es auch genauso gut bedeuten kann, dass sie halt äh auch genug von äh außen bekommen, das mittlerweile als Problem angesehen haben oder dass sie irgendwie ein bisschen über die Stränge geschlagen haben.
Genommen haben, was nicht gepasst hat et cetera.
Ja die Colonia Pipeline Hack, den haben sie spezifisch äh also den angeblich dafür verantwortliche Personen und werden jetzt wohl äh,
eine äh Strafverfolgung äh innerhalb Russlands da ausführen, äh also eine ähm Strafverfahren.
Interessante Entwicklungen, weil's nicht ein hätte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt mit gerechnet.
Da kann man sich natürlich jetzt alle erdenklichen Verschwörungstheorien dazu äh ausdenken so bis hin zu äh,
Lass uns mal ein paar Leute einsammeln, dann machen wir hier mal ein Prozess, dann haben wir was haben wir was getan?
So um um den Druck an der anderen Stelle wieder ein bisschen abzulassen. Kann ja alles nicht bewerten. Äh so was gab's schon. Äh es ist alles durchaus vorstellbar. Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt hier so ist. Werden wir sehen.
Oder vielleicht auch nicht.
Wir werden's sehen. Also ist auf jeden Fall hat mich jetzt ein bisschen überrascht.
So und dann gibt es äh noch ein äh erstaunliches äh juristisches Vorgehen oder ehrlich gesagt nicht so erstaunliches juristisches Vorgehen. Es ist ungefähr ein Jahr
her. Da haben wir hier schon über das Wichtige jeden Tag zu verwendende Tool YouTube-DL gesprochen. Commandine Tool,
YouTube minus DEL. So äh in Python geschrieben, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Ähm was,
unter anderem YouTube-Videos runterladen kann.
Aber auch bei vielen anderen äh Webseiten, die so Medien-Content äh,
bereitstellen und nicht nicht unmittelbar einen Download-Button anbieten, aber auch bei denen, die einen Download-Button anbieten, ähm einfach mal kurz das einfach macht und eine schöne Mediendatei auf den,
ins ins Arbeitsverzeichnis legt. Ja?
Gehostet auf Gitup und ungefähr vor einem Jahr hatte die Recording Industry Asociation of America ähm ein,
Ähm was war das denn? Welche nach welchem.
CFA. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau. Die hatten auf jeden Fall dafür gesorgt, dass dieser Quelltext von Gitarpp verschwindet. Kurzfristig, GTA hat dem.
Erstmal stattgegeben, dann geprüft und hat gesagt, nee, Arsch lecken und hat den äh hat den Quelltext wieder hochgestellt. In diesem Kontext hatten wir hier auch darüber gesprochen.
Gleichzeitig hatten dann die deutschen Ableger von Sony Entertainment Warner Music und äh Universal Music eine Abmahnung an
Uberspace geschrieben. Das ist quasi der Website-Hoster. Also der Code ist auf GITHUP, aber YouTube DEL hat auch eine Webseite
und die liegt bei Overspace, ja? Und da haben die die haben die Overspace abgemahnt und habe gesagt, ihr sollt nicht mehr,
Webseite äh bereitstellen,
Finden wir nicht gut und deswegen mahnen wir euch ab. Dem hat äh nicht ähm entsprochen,
und.
Dann haben die quasi gleichlautend mit dem Abmahntext eine äh Klage eingereicht. Und,
Diese Klage ähm haben sie natürlich da, wo sie hingehört, ans welches Landgericht macht man Urheberrechtsklagen Tim?
Landgericht Hamburg.
Richtig. Seit Jahren steht's zu Diensten und ähm
Das Landgericht ähm Hamburg hat jetzt halt äh dann gesagt, ja okay, das äh verhandeln wir. Ja, dieses Thema verhandeln wir jetzt. Und jetzt ist die Frage,
Was? Auf welcher Basis eigentlich? Ja, also es gibt YouTube TL, ist ein Skript, lädt YouTube-Videos runter. Ähm.
Was ist ist das überhaupt ähm verboten oder nicht? Und warum,
verfolgen, die jetzt ausgerechnet YouTube DE, weil es gibt Browser Plugins, die sind wahrscheinlich, sage ich mal, in der Masse weiter verbreitet als als YouTube-DL. Ja? Ähm,
wie gesagt, ich ich nutze YouTube DEL sehr häufig, aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass das jetzt so so ein Standardtool ist, was alle,
jetzt so in der Masse der Bevölkerung so zu einem großen Problem der Musikindustrie wird.
Was für Nerds.
Ist ein Commanden ein Tool, ja? Es ist eine relativ begrenzter Nutzerbasis, die ist äh,
So und jetzt versuchen wir es mal juristisch zu erklären, denn.
Es gibt in in der deutschen Gesetzgebung das Oxymoron wirksamer Kopierschutz, darf nicht umgangen werden,
Ähm was ja also ne, wenn der wirksam ist, dann kann er ja nicht umgangen werden, sagt äh der eine und
das spielte zum Beispiel spielte eine Rolle bei den Kopierschutzfunktionalitäten von DVDs damals ne mit dem Content Scrumling System wo dann irgendwann dieser Masterkey mal aus einem DVD-Player rausgekratzt wurde und ähm
danach dann überhaupt das,
Kopieren oder Rippen von DVDs dadurch möglich wurde und da gab's dann auch quasi diese Diskussion, darf man diesen Kopierschutz umgehen, weil er nun mal kaputt ist? Oder darf man ihn nicht umgehen, weil er theoretisch hätte funktionieren können?
Und ähm YouTube-Videos haben auch so einen äh Rolling Scypher oder oder ja Cyber ist vielleicht zu viel gesagt, aber so ein also du kannst nicht einfach nur das Video runterladen.
Ja, das würde nicht gehen. So habe ich das jetzt verstanden. Ich dachte eigentlich sogar, dass ginge, aber es ist quasi marginal äh,
eine marginale Abweichung vom Standard, kann man's jetzt mal so leihenmäßig erklären, ähm die das,
direkte Herunterladen von Judos,
erschwert, ja? Und in den Nutzungsbedingungen von YouTube wird das herunterladen auch nicht verboten. Es wird nur gesagt, es ist verboten, wenn es nicht ausdrücklich erlaubt ist.
Und ähm,
spezifisch, sagen Sie sogar, indem du dein Originalvideo mit einer Creative Commons Lizenz versiehst, was ja eine Option ist, die du bei YouTube auswählen kannst. Erlaubst du der gesamten YouTube-Community es wieder zu verwenden und zu bearbeiten,
Und um das wiederzuverwenden und zu bearbeiten, müssen sie's natürlich runterladen und dann in ihr,
iMovie oder womit auch immer die arbeiten äh da reinzaubern, um es irgendwie zu verändern. Ja, ist ja klar. Du kannst also dafür musst du's ja einmal herunterladen. Also es ist offenbar von YouTube nicht intendiert als Kopierschutz.
Der äh Chef von Uberspace sagt, hat ein sehr schönes Zitat auch dazu. Wenn man auf Google, YouTube, Download googelt,
und YouTube gehört ja nun mal Google.
Ist ähm als erstes äh als es eines von den ersten äh Suchergebnissen eine extra Infobox mit dem Wikipedia Eintrag von YouTube DEL.
Also quasi
Google-Feature nochmal spezifisch, nicht nur das Suchergebnis, sondern er hat nochmal eine Infobox und sagt, guck mal hier, das ist das Tool zum Downloaden von unserem Kontext und dazu
sagt er, wenn YouTube doch so sehr daran gelegen ist, Downloads zu unterbinden, könnte zumindest Google als Eigner ja schon mal dafür sorgen, nicht selbst prominent auf das vermutlich verbreitete Download-Tool hinzuweisen. Hat er einen Punkt, ja?
Und die Frage ist eben jetzt oder der Verdacht ist, dass sie und den Verdacht halte ich nicht für unwahrscheinlich, gezielt,
sich diesen spezifischen Fall rausgesucht haben.
Und gezielt dieses Tool, weil sie damit ein weiteres Grundsatzurteil in Sachen Umgehen von Anführungszeichen wirksamen Kopierschutz ähm.
Sich erhoffen. Ja? Ähm.
Also es ist nicht klar, also es ist nicht klar, dass dieses Tool verboten ist.
Und ähm es kann aber sehr gut sein, dass die in Hamburg versuchen eben ähm ein Grundsatzurteil zu erreichen, denn Overspace,
wäre ja erstmal eigentlich durch das Provider Privileg geschützt.
Sind nicht und unmittelbar dafür haftbar, was da bereitgestellt wird, zumal sie ja sogar den Code nicht selber haben, sondern der auf YouTube ist. Also es ist äh eine,
äh interessante Angelegenheit und man darf ja in diesem Kontext auch nicht vergessen, dass ähm,
gesamte.
Themenbereich Musik auf YouTube und schon immer beschäftigt, ne? Wir haben ja jahrelange Auseinandersetzungen,
der GEMA mit YouTube gehabt, weil sie sich nicht darüber einigen konnten, was YouTube Pro Musikstream zahlen soll.
Und YouTube äh also die Musikindustrie hat mit Content ID ja schon ein ein Filterinstrument um irgendwie Inhalte von YouTube runterzuholen und was nicht alles, ja und ich meine, ich muss auch
Also ich frage mich ehrlich gesagt ey wer lädt denn jetzt also wenn det wenn die muss es also wer lädt sich denn ein YouTube-Video runter um da die Musik zu extrahieren?
Also das ist doch eh scheiß Soundqualität oder?
Och na ja also ich hab's aber schon mal gemacht.
Ja, vor 20 Jahren im Usnet.
Nö.
Ja, also da muss man jetzt wieder aufpassen, weil in genau solchen also ich denke, dass es hier wie gesagt mit der These bin ich auch nicht alleine. Das ist hier eher ein Grundsatzurteil angestreibt, angestrebt wird, dass mit diesen.
Äh diese mit diesen DRM,
also nicht funktionale DRM-Verschlüsselung irgendwie per Gesetz dann als wirksam definieren oder
per Lesung, per Lesen des Gesetzes. Mir ist das irgendwie äh
Ist irgendwie ein bisschen komisch, zumal grade YouTube-DL gibt es unzählige Alternativen, ne. Wie gesagt, das ich glaube eigentlich, dass so die Browser Plugins, Video Downloader oder sowas
äh am Ende verbreiteter sind und da haben sie sich offenbar offenbar nicht so für interessiert.
Es gibt auch tausend Fox und Varianten davon. Ich empfehle übrigens allen äh mal äh äh Y T Strich DLP noch etwas kryptischer auszuprobieren. Das ist so ein Fog, der funktioniert sogar noch ein bisschen besser als YouTube-DL.
Ach wat. Und wofür steht das P? Pro.
Nicht. Keine Ahnung. Das ist irgendwie kryptische Logik, die ich nicht weiter hinterfrage. Auf jeden Fall funktioniert das Tool im Prinzip genauso. Aber neulich äh waren die Downloads mit YouTube äh DEL doch sehr langsam.
Irgendwie sind die da irgend äh über irgendeine.
Blockade von YouTube gestoßen. So das sind nur noch in in Echtzeit runterladen konnten. Ich weiß nicht, ob's noch so ist, aber mit äh.
Stimmt, ich hätte.
T Strich DLP geht das auf jeden Fall fix.
Okay, weißt du, dass mir nicht aufgefallen ist? Also ich hatte das auch letztens, dass ich so ein YouTube-DL laufen hatte und der war irgendwie langsam.
Und dann also habe ich hier von vom Laptop laufen lassen und dann bin ich auf einen Server von mir gegangen und dann ging der auf einmal schnell.
Was mich dann auch irgendwie wunderte, wer denn da meine YouTube-Datei-Übertragung weil.
Also ich habe nicht richtig rausgefunden, woran es lag. Ich dachte schon, YouTube hätte jetzt generell ähm nur noch irgendwie in Abspielgeschwindigkeit oder so, aber dem scheint nicht so zu sein.
Okay, also das klingt mir jetzt so ein bisschen äh nach nach Spekulation, dass man jetzt mit YT DIP auch schneller runterläd,
Sie bewerben jetzt erst mal nur, sie hätten Editional Features and Fixes.
Na ja nicht nicht, dass Sie sagen, sie seien schneller, sondern YouTube DEL war aus Gründen, die ich nicht benennen kann, auf einmal in Streaming-Geschwindigkeit sozusagen.
In einer Situation deines Lebens war es mal langsam.
Nein nein, das war ab einem bestimmten Tag bei allen Dateien, mit denen ich's gemacht habe, immer langsam.
Also als ich hatte erst vermutet, dass YouTube irgendwas geändert hat und,
irgendwie diesen Client erkennt oder generell nur noch in Real Time raus wirft.
Sie ja theoretisch auch machen, dass Sie die Daten nicht schneller liefern als man braucht, um sie,
in Echtzeit anzuzeigen, wobei das bestimmt tausend Probleme mit Cashing und Optimierung und Hass nicht gesehen nach sich gezogen hätte. Nur dann bin ich eben auf das äh IT DLP äh äh gestoßen und
habt's parallel vom selben Rechner aus auf dieselbe URL draufgeworfen und da ging's dann halt äh fix frammig. Warum? Keine Ahnung, das wissen bestimmt irgendwelche
von uns äh besser. Äh freue mich auf eure Kommentare und falls ihr dasselbe Problem hattet, habe ich euch jetzt das äh habe ich euch jetzt vielleicht die Lösung für eure Probleme
hört ihr diesen Podcast.
YTLP is a YouTube the air Fork based on the now in active YouTube the LC. So sieht's nämlich aus.
Ja ja es ist äh ein Rattenloch, in das man da reinklettern.
Okay, aber äh genau, also diese Tools sind gut und ähm äh diese Musikindustrie ich. Unsere äh Solidarität mit allen YouTube-Dezentralhostern.
So, da hat der Thomas uns noch eine Stellenausschreibung äh mit reingeworfen in die Shownotes, der Thomas Loninger.
Von Epi Center Works regelmäßig hier zu Gast. Und zwar haben die ausgeschrieben IT-System,
Administratorin und Programmiererinnen männlich, weiblich divers. Ähm die haben Peace-Center Works gibt's ja seit mehreren Jahren. Ähm haben.
Äh grundsätzlich äh Dienstort in Wien, aber Remote und Teleworking sind möglich. Ich meine, ne als Admin musst du,
wahrscheinlich eh übers Internet an deine Server ähm und haben da ein paar ne so die Software-Komponenten, die sie da beschäftigen, mal aufgelistet und ähm.
Sie suchen ja eine erfahrene Person, die das möglichst zeitnah ähm übernimmt.
Ich glaube aber auch ausm persönlichen Gespräch mit Thomas, dass sie jetzt nicht notwendigerweise unbedingt eine festangestellte Person jetzt suchen. Also da steht,
Sie also sie suchen sie bieten eine Festanstellung an. Ja, sie sind aber glaube ich auch durchaus ähm.
Bereit vielleicht äh oder äh mit Dienstleistervertrag, selbstständiger Anstellung oder sonstigem äh zu arbeiten.
Hauptsache die Scheiße läuft.
Ja ja so kannst du dir vorstellen ne? Denke das ist so von der von dem was ich von der Infrastruktur sehe sagen wir mal so. Wenn du das fest angestellt machst hast du auf jeden Fall genug Zeit noch andere Dinge zu machen neben deiner Festanstellung,
wenn du das ähm.
Einmal ordentlich hochziehst und wenn du's äh wenn du es selbstständig machst äh ja hast du hast du gut was zu tun eine Zeit lang und ja
Also könnt ihr euch ja mal anschauen, wer sich da angesprochen fühlt, wer Freelance so was macht oder zum Beispiel auch sagt, keine Ahnung, ich bin als äh Süß-Admin,
ähm Freelancerin unterwegs, ich äh könnte mir vorstellen, dass für die zu machen ist ja auch eine NGO, vielleicht,
möchte ich da ein bisschen zu günstigeren Kursen für die Arbeiten, um das mal ordentlich hochzuziehen oder so bietet sich da eine,
Gelegenheit ist äh verlinkt.
Genau, bitte melde dich.
Jo, ich hoffe, das habe ich jetzt alles richtig wieder gegeben, glaube ich aber schon.
Heute sind wir am Ende der Sendung. Kurz und knapp.
Zwanziger kommen immer näher, läuft.
Nicht zu sagen Leute. Insofern wünschen wir euch eine schöne äh erfolgreiche Woche und ähm das euch nicht ärgern und äh wir hören uns.
Bis dahin, tschau, tschau.
Tschüss.